[Musique]
vous avez pas marre que vous passez
l'agitateur en permanence au non au
contraire que des bruits de micro
non ça va voilà non non je suis très
content c'était bon tu crois plus de six
cent mille exemplaires 984 millions
j'ai dû rester à peu près une demi heure
un studio larnack de crédit agricole
c'est moins les dlc ou ce raccord rome
et d'europe et la coupe intertoto 984
millions est ce qu'avec le single on
vise cinq ans derrière
non pas du tout non j'ai gagné un petit
peu d'argent mais quand on a une
vingtaine d'années on dépense facilement
mal à gagner des fortunes mais si celui
qui écrit qui gagnent beaucoup
d'ailleurs la france de quad après pour
qu'on essaie de comprendre comment ça
rapporte quoi c'est que j'ai dû gagner
deux cent mille euros bruts à peu près
parce que au départ on me dit pas on a
beaucoup de taxes et cetera dessus ou
m200 200000 droit 20 ans excuse moi
c'est que we may 21 narbonne à 49
secondes d'abord revenir au battersea
tout pour ce qu'ils puissent tenir parce
qu'on a posé une question s'arrête pas
là ok mais tu vis pas tu t'amuses quand
tu es à paris que tu es nouveau
oui bien sûr mathieu oui on retourne en
2001 c'est magnifique vous étiez mince
on repart en 2001 c'est la star ac
à la différence et demi finale et c'est
jenifer qui gagne souvenez vous
[Musique]
rappelez-vous en 2001 a débarqué la
magie harry potter puis un sorcier
2001 7 at il ya 17 ans kylie ann papé
avait deux ans emmanuel macron on avait
lui à peine 23 il sans doute avait-il
dans sa poche un objet particulièrement
convoité l'ipod avec certainement le
tube de l'époque
en cette rentrée 2001 harry potter est
inscrit au château de poudlard et un
certain jean pascal à celui de
dammarie-les-lys option star ac' imiter
d'ailleurs il a bien fait de prendre des
cours de chant le jp c'est pas le talent
et ils étouffent quand il passe le
casting de l'émission
attention à vos oreilles je suis désolé
lol petit lait et leurs chapeaux si jean
pascal n'est pas un rossignol il a
d'autres atouts
il est beau gosse et à l'oral en plus le
mec il assouvit des villes quand même un
jour en allant surfer on a vu trois
enfants soit balayée par une vague
donc on est allé les chercher on en a
sauvé les a sauvés de la noyade et c'est
ce qui m'a donné l'envi 2
date qu'ont pied volontaire sur les
plages du coup le jb il peut pécho à
l'aise
je suis à force de pousser la
chansonnette à la star academy première
saison jean pascal décroche un disque
d'or en 2002 avec son titre qui es tu
une question existentielle film original
après la chanson ils se rêvent comédiens
en 2006 le voilà adjudant-chef dans la
série section de recherches
mais cette saison ça use il reprend
alors ses quartiers sur la côte basque
patron de guinguette visé moi ça dans le
rétro nous avons donc maîtres nageurs
chanteur acteur patron de resto alors
pour la rentrée 2010 8
on se demande bien ce qu'il nous a
préparé le gip et l'animal s'était
rencontré à cette époque là pardon on
serait toujours en somme c'est vrai de
business qu'on aurait plein de choses à
cette époque là où elle et elle est bien
chaude à cela la dame est un
professionnel bien sûr j'entends dire eh
oui j'aime bien aller elle est
magnifique aussi un cd bons souvenirs
tout ça très très way et le reportage
est très bien fait je remercie beaucoup
alors j'ai même vous dire la vérité
quand on a préparé cette émission on a
des gens passent comme un invité mais on
a discuté un petit peu avant parce qu'on
avait l'idée comme sur vous saurez tout
même s'ils refusent on avait l'idée
peut-être de vous demander devenir
chroniqueur dans l'émission parce qu'on
veut un peu un beau gosse un peu grande
gueule tout ça comme méditer mais la
proposition avait été faite
vous saviez non
[Rires]
on en a produit des effets un petit peu
fait voilà on a vu lille sur quatre est
bien marcher leurs jeux sur ipad interne
patronat prévoit en tout cas si vous
n'êtes pas trop les airs et bon voilà
mais au niveau du temps avait fauché je
joue au golf un peu j'ai une vie j'ai
bien compris que vous dit rien [ __ ]
j'ai bien compris
alors on va repasser quelques à quelques
questions d'image notamment parce qu' un
truc qui moi qui me fascine c'est que
star ac à l'époque c'était quand même on
a un petit brin de voix on s'est un peu
chantée
donc on va à la star academy et on
apprend encore mieux chanter à devenir
une star or logiquement logiquement or
vous ne saviez psion pas chanter vous
n'avez pas envie de venir chanter je ne
sais toujours pas le faire nos jeunes se
souvient notamment d'un prime avec vous
deviez chanter du patrick bruel on avait
toutes les images
oui c'est quand même quelque chose c'est
un rappel sur tf1 regardez
[Applaudissements]
c'est à dire vendéen
nous
mais même pas
book excusez moi c'est indirect je crois
qu'il ya eu
problème c'est un vent c'est un peu vite
[Applaudissements]
jean pascal a g6
ce cas
[Applaudissements]
accor est sûre peu avant le jean le site
jean pascal s'il a bien fait parce qu'il
me doit vraiment tu peux vraiment cette
stèle panahi si c'est vrai ça vaut
d'être non mais on est dans l'exemple
regarde ça me dis pas que c'est à la
mode en 2001 comme les cuisses d'une
grande salle à l'exemple même de ce
qu'est la télé réalité c'est à dire que
c'était la première est ce qu'on veut
donc quand on fait des émissions de télé
réalité c'est pas tellement des gens
légitime c'est avant tout des
personnages qu'on le veuille ou non jean
pascal est un personnage par huit mois
n'est pas de bien chanter non lui
demander d'être calé d'ailleurs comme il
est et ce qu'il est et ce qu'il est
toujours sympathique authentic avec
l'accent et tout ça qu'il est hors cote
à dax eh ben il a marché à la télévision
et la preuve c'est qu'un prêt toujours